with the rise of affordable streaming
services like netflix disney plus and
hulu we've seen a significant reduction
in piracy over the past several years
but for those that still engage in
piracy there's no doubt that taunting is
the key that makes it all possible
if you're not familiar with the
torrenting it's basically a file
distribution system that makes it
extremely difficult to shut down piracy
instead of downloading a file from a
central server with torrents you
download the file from thousands of
other people who have already downloaded
the file themselves so piracy sites like
the piratebay and kick-ass torrents
don't actually host the files themselves
they just have to host the torrenting
links that connect pirates from around
the world so if prosecutors take down a
certain piracy website the hosts of the
website just have to upload the links to
a new website which is no more than a
few gigabytes
in other words they don't have to move
the exabytes of data associated with the
links themselves this ease of moving
websites has made it impossible to shut
down large websites like the pirate bay
as they can just constantly move
websites thanks to torrents as you would
guess prosecutors and copyright holders
aren't exactly big fans of the man who
invented torrence braumcoin but at the
same time they can't do anything about
it so here's the story of braum cohen
and how he accidentally invented the
soul of piracy
taking a look back braum was born on
october 12 1975 in manhattan new york
his father was a computer scientist and
his mother was a schoolteacher so it
looks like the family didn't have too
much trouble financially from a very
early age it was clear that braum wasn't
like most kids he had rather mature
interests and excelled at stimulated
competitions for example when he was
just five years old he was trying to
learn the programming language basic and
let's not forget when braum was five it
was 1980. even today a five-year-old
learning computer science would be quite
impressive but given how much exposure
children have to technology today it
would make a lot more sense back in 1980
though the average person didn't even
know why they needed a computer in the
first place aside from an interest in
programming braum participated in
several competitions such as the usa
math olympiad despite this inclination
towards academics it doesn't seem like
baum was that sold on the idea of school
he didn't stack on degree after degree
instead he attended the university of
buffalo and as soon as he started
getting job offers he left and never
looked back braum's career throughout
the 1990s wasn't that stable though
it's not clear if braum couldn't qualify
for a job at a big tech company like
microsoft or cisco or if he was trying
to hit a big with the startup but either
way this forced him to constantly switch
jobs as each startup he worked for went
under while the startup world wasn't too
kind to brahm it did provide him with
unique concepts and ideas and this was
especially true with this last job at
mojo nation mojo nation was trying to
create a decentralized method for safely
storing and distributing confidential
files the idea was that encrypted chunks
of the original file could be spread
across multiple computers this way to
download the entire file you would need
cooperation from all the computers so a
hacker couldn't just get access to one
of these computers and steal the entire
file it's not clear if this
decentralized encryption method ever
caught on but this idea did inspire
braum who thought that it was perfect
for file sharing
in april of 2001 braum went ahead and
quit mojo nation determined to bring his
file sharing idea to life over the next
year he programmed the first bittorrent
client which ran on python
soon enough braum completed a beta
version of the software that worked
alright but braum was well aware that
the key to success was not the program
itself but getting people to see it
so he worked with his roommate len
sasman to create a tech conference that
you might have heard of codecon since
then even people as notable as sergey
bin and elon musk have presented on
codecon but braum and bittorrent were
the stars of the first code con this
presentation allowed braum to create
some hype within the tech world but this
was not exactly his target audience per
se
so rom developed a new idea to attract
users in the summer of 2002 rom went out
and got some adult films and offered
them for free on bittorrent this
strategy was surprisingly effective but
braum didn't want to be known as an
adult film distributor so after he built
up a solid base of users he stopped
seeing these films by this point though
many bittorrent users started to realize
the true potential of the program
nowadays we have extremely reliable
cloud storage platforms like google
drive and mega which allow users to
download gigabytes with their files in a
matter of minutes but back in the early
2000s moving around such large files was
not only difficult but expensive due to
the storage and bandwidth requirements
so no one wanted to host such files with
a bittorrent though no single person had
to host the files
instead hundreds or even thousands of
users could host them and given that
average people aren't charged for the
bandwidth usage this was basically free
from most hosts considering these perks
i don't think you'd be surprised to hear
that bittorrent became the go-to place
to share and download large files
and naturally it's not like people need
a bittorrent share four gigabyte word
documents or excel spreadsheets no the
most common files that were large enough
to require bittorrent were movies games
and software and as users started to
realize how easily such files could be
shared using bittorrent the program
quickly became the soul of piracy
given bittorrent's major role within
piracy it's not surprising that
bittorrent was a massive target for
prosecutors but the problem was that
they couldn't really charge bittorrent
or braum for copyright infringement
braum had made it clear that he didn't
create bittorrent for piracy his main
goal was to simply allow users to share
and to download lodge files cheaper
faster and more efficiently than ever
before
and it just so happens that the
community started using it for illicit
activities so given that there was no
conspiracy to commit copyright
infringement prosecutors can't do
anything
it would be like the fbi taking action
against facebook because cameras are
using whatsapp to conduct bitcoin scams
with that being said though piracy is a
way bigger part of bittorrent than
bitcoin scams are of whatsapp so
prosecutors were constantly looking for
ways to build a case against bittorrent
but braum was well aware of this and he
was extremely cautious he didn't pirate
himself he didn't encourage others to
pirate and he constantly tried to make
bittorrent more applicable to other use
cases as well
that was basically braum's legal stance
on the piracy issue his moral stance
however was a lot different braum
believes that copyright holders need to
get alive and stop going after every
medium that inadvertently enables piracy
he argues that if copyrighted content
was offered in an affordable and easily
accessible way people would have no
reason to part content and this does
make sense given what happened to the
music industry back in the 2000s it was
extremely common to pirate music to put
on mp3 players and ipods but with the
explosive growth of youtube spotify and
apple music music piracy has
significantly declined i mean why would
you go on to sketchy websites and risk
getting a virus when you can legally
listen to any song on youtube or spotify
for free with ads or for a reasonable
fee without ads so i do think braum's
argument makes some sense but this
didn't stop copyright holders from
trying to fight back anyway
since copyright holders couldn't
directly shut down or convict bittorrent
they decided to go after the ones that
were sharing the content themselves
initially this included bittorrent as
well as they had links to copyrighted
material on their official website but
in 2005 braum made a deal with seven
american studios that he would remove
all piracy related links from their
website this led to the rise of sites
like the pirate bay and kick-ass torns i
have videos on both these websites if
you're interested but in this video
we'll be focusing on cedars
cedars are basically the thousands of
hosts around the world that are making
the content available to pirate and
since copyright holders couldn't take
down bittorrent they decided to take
down cedars copyright holders started
finding the ip addresses of cders and
contacting their internet service
providers to cut their internet
considering these consequences you might
be wondering why would anybody see
content well within the piracy community
it's common courtesy to seed for as long
as you download it but even if you don't
see it out of free will you'll
automatically be seating after
downloading the content itself for
example if you're pirating avengers end
game and your progress bar is at 80
percent this means that you've already
downloaded the first 80 which you could
be seeing after downloading the last 20
copyright holders have actually gotten
really good at identifying seeders and
cutting their internet which has forced
most pirates to start using vpns which
is quite ironic
if you're pirating any amount of
substantial content you're gonna have to
get a paid vpn expressvpn's cheapest
option itself costs one hundred dollars
per year meanwhile disney plus only
costs eighty dollars per year so clearly
there is some sort of disparity going on
here if pirates are more willing to pay
for a vpn than a streaming service as
braum suggested nonetheless copyright
holders have continued to spend a lot of
effort in taking down cders
for many founders within the piracy
community there is no life after
founding the piracy website most of them
have several charges against them they
owe millions to copyright holders and
order fugitives on the run but given
that braum was always able to stay on
the legal side of the law there's
nothing restricting him and he's used
this freedom to move past bittorrent in
2017 braum founded a cryptocurrency
company called chia network one of the
main goals of the company was to move
cryptocurrency away from proof of work
and on to proof of stake if you're not
sure what that means it basically means
eliminating the need for miners chia
launched their coin in may of 2021 and
it hasn't been doing so hot in fact it's
down 95 from its peak but it should be
noted that the coin was launched at the
peak of the altcoin bull run so overall
crypto sentiment hasn't been too kind to
chia with that being said though given
the existence of much more popular
projects with similar goals like solana
and cardano it's not clear if chia will
ever take off at the end of the day bomb
was the mastermind behind the pilot
sharing protocol that made piracy what
it is today
despite the status within the piracy
community prosecutors can't really do
anything to brahm given that he didn't
create bittorrent with the intention of
pirating it nor does he encourage or
promote piracy this has allowed him to
live a rather free life relative to
other piracy kings but none of his other
projects thus far have achieved similar
levels of success to bittorrent and
that's the story of the torrenting thing
that the fbi can't do anything about
have you ever used bittorrent comment
that down below
also drop a like if you're thankful for
torrenting for legal purposes of course
and consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one